wie funktioniert die eu
die europäische union wird von fünf
grossen institutionen gelenkt
europäischer rat eu parlament rat der eu
europäische kommission europäische
gerichtshof
der europäische rat trifft sich
mindestens vier mal im jahr auf einem eu
gipfel
hier geben die staats und
regierungschefs die richtung für europa
vor und definieren allgemeine ziele wie
zum beispiel die einführung des euro
das eu-parlament wird alle fünf jahre
von den eu bürgern direkt gewählt
die hauptaufgabe des parlaments ist es
gesetze zu beschließen
dies kann das parlament aber nur
gemeinsam mit dem rat der eu
dieser besteht aus den fachministern der
mitgliedsländer
sie werden von den landesregierungen in
den rat geschickt so kommen je nach
thema beispielsweise die außen und
umweltminister der mitgliedstaaten
zusammen jeder minister steht im rat für
die stimme seines landes
der rat und das parlament können zwar
gemeinsam gesetze beschließen aber nicht
selbst vorschlagen
dies kann jedoch die europäische
kommission die kommission macht aber
nicht nur selbst vorschläge
sie kann auch vom parlament dazu
aufgefordert werden gesetzentwürfe
vorzulegen
jedes mitgliedsland stellt in der
kommission einen kommissar oder eine
kommissarin welche vom eu parlament
gewählt werden
ebenfalls vom parlament der eu gewählt
wird der präsident der europäischen
kommission
die kommissare sollen unabhängig von
ihren herkunftsländern im sinne europas
handeln
jeder kommissar hat ein eigenes
aufgabengebiet die kommission
entscheidet aber gemeinsam sie achtet
darauf dass sich die mitgliedstaaten an
gesetze und verträge halten falls nicht
kann die kommission warnungen
aussprechen bußgelder verhängen und
klagen vor dem europäischen gerichtshof
einreichen
der europäische gerichtshof greift immer
dann ein wenn es trotz gesetzen zwischen
den ländern zu streitigkeiten kommt und
diese nicht anders beigelegt werden
können er besteht aus einem richter pro
mitgliedsland grundlegend passt der
europäische gerichtshof auf dass die
mitgliedstaaten die nationalen
institutionen und gerichte sowie die
institutionen der eu das eu recht
einhalten